and for those people and with that
weather if you have plans for some fun
in the sun this weekend in lake mead you
are not alone
victoria saha rode along with patrols
today and they share with her
the best advice on how to have a safe
and memorable day
memorial day weekend usually means the
kickstart of summer
and if you're planning on escaping the
heat by heading out to lake mead
state game wardens want you to know the
dangers the water can bring
the sun beaming down at your skin the
wind blowing in your hair
laughter with family and friends it's
what many of you are looking forward to
as las vegas heats up
do a lot of water sports we do the wake
surfing wake boarding
all that fun stuff boaters like ashley
jines and her family are ready for the
weekend
game warden thomas hamlind and his team
are also ready
with key advice think safety first
you're jumping the water and it's 350
feet deep
you can't touch the bottom you don't
have that safety net anymore hamblin
says
tragedies can be prevented earlier this
month a six-year-old girl drowned
while wind was a factor a life jacket
would have saved her life
put your kid in a life jacket they hate
it absolutely i see kids screaming all
the time
but at least they're going to survive
boat owners are required to have life
jackets for every single person on board
but they don't need to wear that but if
you're 12 years old and under
you need to be wearing one at all times
another cause of boating accidents being
under the influence and
not watching out for other watercraft
and swimmers
that's a recipe for disaster
state game wardens are expecting a busy
weekend so they want you to remember
to be courteous to the other boaters
you're sharing the water with
reporting from lake mead victoria saha 8
news now
victoria thank you and a reminder for
boat owners if you are born after
january 1
1983 you are required to have a boater
education card